- Thank you everybody.
I think that's the
first time I've heard it
introduced that way where I heard
thank you for coming to A A 110 Questions.
We don't have 110 questions, it is just 10
and welcome to the 9th session
of this 10-week series.
What Is Knowledge?
What do I know, is the
topic for this evening.
This is our penultimate
session of 10 Questions.
And one of our guests this evening
asked if I could work the
word penultimate in early,
so, check, done.
How do we know what penultimate means?
Most of us know what the word means
but we don't know
exactly how we know that.
We just do.
And with that I introduce tonight's topic
which is to stand back
from our daily lives
organized around the
acquisition of, presentation of,
conservation of knowledge
of various kinds.
And I'm thinking
especially of you students
who will be tested on knowledge
in a couple of weeks time
in various classes.
To think instead about
the larger topic or idea,
this very, very special, very
human, almost incomparable
concept that we have of
knowledge in the world
and how that concept
relates to or differs from
things very close to it,
like ideas, like information,
like many other things that
seems to sit closely aside
this very human quality and concept.
To ask, what is knowledge,
I think if we think about it for a minute
is very abstract, almost obscure or obtuse
compared to some of the
questions we've asked
over the last couple of months.
If you think of beauty, failure, time,
big, human or at times
intensely personal ideas.
To ask, what is knowledge, you gotta admit
sounds a little bit know-it-all-like.
And a very UCLA kinda thing, right?
It is, however, by design, a
question that's gonna lead us
into the final one of this series
which is to contemplate:
What is a University?
And we're joined by some
terrific guests this evening
who are gonna help us with that work.
I'm old enough, I think,
to be comfortable in saying
I feel like I know what I know
and I know what I don't know.
One of the incredible
pleasures of being a dean
at a school like the School
of the Arts and Architecture
at UCLA is I spend my
days literally with people
who know way more than I do.
Including you students, I promise,
you know things that most of us at my age
can't even imagine let alone comprehend.
But all of this focus on
though, in our daily lives
as we contemplate that kind of reality
is, of course, who it is we might turn to
how it is we might think
how it is we relay that
thing we treat as knowledge.
And tonight's work is gonna
continue that sort of thinking.
That said, for me, there are three things
I do know about knowledge.
The first is, it's incredibly valuable
and arguably more valuable than ever
at a time described in relation to
an idea like knowledge economies.
That suddenly place more value
in literal monetary terms on ideas
than it often will on hard stuff
like bricks and mortar, glass or steel.
The second thing I know is
that knowledge is vulnerable.
Particularly, you could
say, in an era of fake news
or rampant conspiracy theory industries.
Whatever it is, is
something that we all need
to think carefully about
protecting and not just conserving.
And finally, knowledge is endurable.
It is enduring, and an enduring feature
of who and what we are as a species.
Whatever else it is, knowledge
is something we humans
produce and value, it's
something we share,
we broadcast, we socialize.
We occasionally monetize
or even monopolize
in spectacular and unexpected ways.
A final way in which we might
think about the importance
of asking questions about
what is knowledge today.
So with that, as something less
than a knowledgeable introduction
I would ask you to welcome
with me our guests this evening
who are going to do work
sharing their knowledge
on the bigger question
of what knowledge is.
Everybody, Kristy Edmunds, Victoria Marks,
Marcelo Suarez-Orozco and Todd Presner.
(audience applauds)
Come on in, you guys.
Thank you so much.
A brief introduction
for each of our guests
and then we're going to
get on with the evening.
On the far side, Kristy
Edmunds is an artist,
a curator, an artistic director
and frequent international consultant
in addition to being the
Executive and Artistic Director
of UCLA's Center for
the Art of Performance.
Kristy's reputation for
innovation and depth
relates to her presentation
of contemporary art
across all disciplines,
with particular emphasis
on contemporary performing arts.
In collaboration with master artists,
she has curated unique
forms that survey the breath
of their artistry while
placing equal emphasis
on the support and
commissioning of new work
by some of today's leading
performance creators.
Everybody, Kristy Edmunds.
(audience applauds)
Thank you, thanks for coming in.
Victoria Marks, here closest
to me, is a choreographer,
and I'm very pleased to say,
our Associate Dean of
Academic Affairs here
at UCLA's School for the
Arts and Architecture.
Victoria is a professor of choreography
in the UCLA Department of
World Arts and Cultures
which has as its home this
wonderful building, Kaufman Hall,
where she has been teaching since 1995.
She creates dances that consider
the politics of citizenship
as well as the representation
of both virtuosity and disability
for the stage, for film
and in community settings.
As you know, Victoria is also the one
who conceived of and developed
this 10 Questions course
to build in her words.
(audience applauds)
Aw, that's wonderful.
To build in her words,
a vital cross-university
conversations as we work
towards understanding
the unique perspectives of each discipline
across larger equations of knowledge.
Marcelo Suarez-Orozco is a
psychological anthropologist
and the Wasserman Dean of
the UCLA Graduate School
of Education and Information Studies.
Marcelo's research focuses on conceptual
and empirical problems in the
areas of cultural psychology
and psychological anthropology
with an emphasis on the
study of mass migration,
globalization, and education.
An immigrant from Argentina,
Marcelo was a product of
the California Master Plan,
having studied in community college
and at Berkeley where
he received his Ph.D.
And in January, Pope Francis
appointed Dean Suarez-Orozco
to the Pontifical Academy
of the Social Sciences.
Everyone, Marcelo Suarez-Orozco.
(audience applauds)
And finally, Todd Presner
is a digital humanist,
a cultural critic,
historian and rock climber.
We'll see which of those skills we use
most immediately this evening.
And the Founding Chair of UCLA's
Digital Humanities Program
and Ross Professor of Germanic Languages
and Comparative Literature.
Since 2018, he is Associate
Dean of Digital Innovation
in the Division of Humanities here at UCLA
and Adviser to the Vice
Chancellor of Research
for Humanities, Arts, and
Social Sciences Research.
Todd's research focuses on
European intellectual history,
the history of media, visual
culture, digital humanities
and cultural geography.
Everybody, Todd Presner.
(audience applauds)
Thank you, thank you all
so much for coming in.
And welcome all, and we will
begin, as we do every week,
with short presentations
by each of our guests.
We have an agreed order,
and we're going to being this
evening with Victoria Marks.
(audience applauds)
- Thank you, Brett Steele and
thank you all for being here.
And I particularly wanna
thank Anne Marie Burke,
Kylie Carrigan and Louise Cale
who have been my compatriots
in creating these events,
this class and these public events.
So thank you to all of you.
I'm a choreographer and
I want to bring the body
into the question, what is knowledge.
I think of the body as
a source of knowing.
And actually I was
looking at the biography
I often use when I'm presenting
my biography to people
and it often says,
Victoria Marks practices
knowing and unknowing, making
dances for stage and film.
I thought about that and
actually I really, really like
the idea of unknowing,
because I like knowing so much
that if I unknown it, I can do it again,
I can know things differently
and see things anew.
So, I wanna step aside from
my presentation for a moment.
I just wanna ask you
all, how are you feeling?
(audience murmurs)
Okay, so-so, I get a
little so-so, some great.
I'm wondering if maybe
you're a little bit tired,
because it's the end of a long day?
- [Man] Tired.
(audience murmurs)
Yeah, hungry, 'cause it's dinner time?
Yeah, maybe a little bit horny?
Because you're young and wild.
(audience titters)
Most, everybody is young and wild.
Okay, well, actually I just, it's time now
to get back to my lecture
and I just wanna ask you
to put your mind over matter, please.
And for those of you who are
still thinking about horny
and kinda checking in on that,
get your mind out of the gutter.
(audience laughs)
Okay, the way I understand this is.
If we look back into European history
Rene Descartes attempted
to prove the nature
of human existence through
the action of thought.
In what has become a fundamental
paradigm for knowledge,
we remember his words.
- [Audience Members] I
think, therefore I am.
- Okay, in two languages,
I think, therefore I am.
Oh, excuse me, would you mind?
Stand up, please.
Thank you so much.
They've already agreed to this before.
We have the mind and the body.
(audience laughs)
And I just wanted to
give you a visual on this
because in Descartes' thinking,
the mind and the body were
separable and distinct.
So, the mind often to referred
to a higher plane of knowledge
and the body would be living
(audience laughs)
in the muck or the
gutter of living itself.
We might think of the mind as culture.
And we might think of the body as nature
or the place where all the shit happens.
Literally.
First of all, these guys were
just so generous to do this.
I just wanna thank you
and I will carry on.
I will carry on.
(audience applauds)
The other week, Susan Foster,
in talking about the body,
said that it's redundant
to say embodied knowledge.
What she was telling us is
that knowledge is embodied.
So let's not look at the body
as an object to be studied
but actually as a source for knowing.
Okay, next choreographic enterprise.
Everything we know comes
from our experience.
We're in a continuous sensory conversation
with what's going on outside
of us and inside of us.
Now, we might think
about the body's inside
being contained by the
membrane of the skin
or it's connection to the outside
through the membrane of the skin.
But actually, as a
choreographer, I think of it
I think of the ends of our
body more as our kinosphere
the space around our bodies.
But if you drive a car,
which, how many of you do drive a car?
Quite a few of you.
Okay, sometimes when you're in a car a lot
that car feels as though
it's the outer membrane of your body.
And sometimes, in the best of times
when we're in a room together
and something happens
that we're all a part of
in which we are transformed
we feel that we are
collectively an organism
and we share a membrane of understanding
and we take what happens
in that room outside
and we affect what's going
on outside of the room.
Listen, I just want to
apologize to you, now.
Because, I'm really
sorry, I had to lie down.
And I know it was the wrong thing to do.
(audience titters)
But I did it for a reason,
because I'm trying to point out
the knowledge we have of the
appropriate bodily comportment
within the circumstances of a lecture.
You are all admirably demonstrating
your understanding of how
it is to be in a lecture.
You're sitting quietly.
Most of you are looking at me.
Your eyes are open.
You're breathing quietly.
If you've got your computer open,
you're probably taking notes.
So, I think that that demonstrates
that we have a shared knowledge
about what's appropriate
for being in a lecture.
But just to take that a step further
first of all, I'd like to,
can anybody whistle like this?
(person whistles)
Okay, thank you.
(audience laughs)
The next time you hear that whistle,
I'd like to invite
everyone here to misbehave.
Now, just a couple of rules.
Don't hurt yourself, don't
hurt the person next to you
and please don't wreck the property.
You have 10 seconds to misbehave.
When you hear the whistle the second time
please, please stop, okay?
All right, ready?
(person whistles)
(audience clamors)
(audience laughs)
And.
(person whistles)
Thank you very much.
So you know what misbehavior is,
proving what the appropriate behavior is.
And for those of you who refused my offer,
was there anyone who refused my offer?
Okay, well I can think of two things.
Either you have so absorbed
the authoritative requirements
for being in a lecture,
maybe you felt that you
couldn't really misbehave.
Or, and I bet it's the second.
You were asked to transgress,
and you thought to yourself,
oh, the authoritative voice in the room
is asking me to transgress,
and so, if I transgress
that is not transgressing
and therefore if I sit still
(audience laughs)
and I don't transgress, then
I will be really thwarting
the appropriate behavior in the room.
I see you nodding your
heads yes, so now I know.
(audience laughs)
Here's my next act.
We elevate some kinds of
knowledge and dismiss others.
Okay.
Consider the many everyday
techniques you know
and let's, for example,
think about the technique of driving.
How many of you drive?
Okay, good.
And we know that, uh oh. (blowing)
We know that you drive (laughing)
okay, listen, we know that
you drive very, very well
because you're here.
And how many of you,
I mean, oh, nevermind.
I'm not gonna ask for numbers.
But also, most of us know
the appropriate comportment
and etiquette for eating, is that correct?
Good, so we can have dinner together.
But basically, these are techniques.
They are techniques
which you have perfected
or quickly, hopefully, will soon perfect
your skills in these areas.
And you do that through repetition.
You just do it over
and over and over again
until it begins to feel natural.
So nothing actually is natural,
but we have the experience of something
we've learned as being natural
when we have repeated it so often
that we no longer have to bring
an attenuated focus to every next move.
We have absorbed that knowledge.
As long as that's clear.
When you do a headstand, by
the way, I can do a headstand
but I'm just a little
nervous to do it right now.
(audience laughs)
But when you do a headstand
at a club or at a party
or maybe like in a lecture hall.
Or at home in your living room.
You are displaying technique.
And you are demonstrating
a set of skills, knowledge.
And when you are really, really good,
you're able to generate new ideas
within your headstanding technique.
And I'll just let you
imagine what that could be.
All dancers study technique,
whether in the studio or on the street.
And mastery of technique
allows for freedom within that technique.
But what I want to say here is technique
is not about learning movement alone.
Not at all.
When you practice a technique,
whether dancing or eating dinner,
or driving your car, or washing,
you enact a set of beliefs and values.
All techniques are philosophical practices
that locate personhood and
also collective beliefs.
Each technique puts us in
the world in its own way.
Dancing is ephemeral.
Like life.
It leaves no tangible trace.
It's here and gone.
And when dancers work, their
labor leaves no object,
no commodity that can be owned or sold.
Only, as in life, a visceral
memory of lives fully lived
precariously and with great love.
If we view our bodies as things,
as objects to be studied,
controlled and subdued, then by extension,
we have a template through which
to objectify and control others.
We're accustomed to thinking of power,
the dominion of some
people over other people,
some communities over other communities,
nations over nations,
humans over animals,
humans over the earth.
And when we, in the hubris
of our own elevated status
look down at animals or other people
this reductive act diminishes knowledge
and then we call it instinct.
And that enables us to kill.
When we attempt to control the body,
to treat the body as an
object that we subdue,
which may be in part
necessary for our survival,
that same act of control
can be a form of assault
on knowledge itself.
What if instead of positioning knowledge
solely as an act of the mind
a state of dominion over the body,
we considered the body
as a source of knowledge
and a way of knowing?
Thank you.
(audience applauds)
- Thank you, Victoria.
Thank you so much, thank you.
Everybody, Todd Presner.
- I'm gonna grab the clicker.
Thank you so much.
It's really a pleasure
to be able to participate
in this experiment with you all.
And thank you Victoria and
Brett, and my colleagues
for allowing me to be here
and share some thoughts.
When I think about the
question, what is knowledge,
immediately I begin to proliferate
a whole set of other questions.
Whose knowledge are we talking about?
Where is this knowledge,
where do we find it?
How did it become knowledge
in the first place?
Who's credentialed it?
Who certified that that's
knowledge there, that's not?
Why this knowledge
as opposed to some
other kind of knowledge?
And, as someone that
works in the field of,
imagine you heard a little bit,
digital humanities is one
thing I do, I work with media,
but I'm also a historian.
I work particularly on German
and German-Jewish history
and I'll get to that in a moment.
But I also think about
knowledge that's varied
and silenced or submerged.
And I wonder a lot about
knowledge that becomes lost
and what it means to find
that knowledge, to excavate it
and particularly when it comes to voices
that have been erased or obliterated
from the cultural record.
That, to me, becomes a
politics of knowledge
and really, in some ways, lays
forward the ethical stakes
of the entire enterprise of
what we do at a university.
Where is knowledge?
Well, oftentimes we think
of things like this.
Grandiose spaces, the Library of Congress,
beautiful, masterful,
architectural, ornate.
Reading rooms and then the
storehouses of knowledge
in stacks in libraries, and
they're organized in nice boxes.
They're cataloged and they're
organized and classified
because knowledge is always
organized and classified.
And in so far as we think
about classification systems
we realize those too are political.
Well, if we go to the history
of even the word archive
we already connect it with power.
It comes from the Greek term archeion.
It means a house or a domicile,
but not just any domicile
or anyone's house,
but the domicile of the
superior magistrates
who are the archeions, those who command.
And so knowledge is
something that's guarded.
Some people have access to
it, can get into the archive,
other people do not.
And that already tells me
that we have to think about the nexus
between knowledge and
power from the get-go.
The Mercator projection,
1596, an amazing feat.
Google maps uses it today
because it's useful for navigation.
It doesn't distort in
the way other maps do.
Very useful for ship
trade, ship navigation.
Slave trade as well.
Printing press, of course, it disseminates
knowledge to the world.
But of course, it creates
a public that can read
and another public that
maybe is illiterate.
We think of the scribal
tradition of writing down text
of translating them.
Who's overseeing them,
what texts get translated,
what texts get lost?
Or the idea of codification
of knowledge into great books.
Philosophical tradition.
I read these great books
when I was in college
and I was like, oh, these
are the great books.
This is knowledge, it's right there.
(audience laughs)
As it turns out, it's a really
small fraction of knowledge.
So, I always have to think about,
knowledge is not just about
power, it's also empowerment.
Because we have the ability to speak back.
And you have to ask the
question, who can speak?
In what languages, in what media?
How are they credentialed, by whom?
What institutions and communities
are involved in organizing
and preserving knowledge?
And especially in so far as
we think about applications of knowledge,
how does knowledge lead to action?
What does it mean that we know something?
Do we actually act on it?
Do we do something about it?
Amazing exhibition right now
by Adrian Piper at the Hammer
that deals with exactly this issue.
I work in the field of
Holocaust and genocide studies.
This, obviously, it's
a deep, difficult field
in a lot of ways.
But genocide, the term genocide
means the killing of a race.
In German, they use the term
(speaking in foreign language)
which means annihilation.
To refer to what the Nazis were gonna do
not just to the Jews, but
especially Jews and other groups
that they considered to be sub-human.
It's not only about the
destruction of a people.
It's also the destruction of knowledge.
It's a destruction of culture.
It's a destruction of society.
It's the destruction of
the historical record
and that's really what's at stake
when we begin to think about
power and power over others.
Hannah Arendt's a great
German-Jewish philosopher
who herself escaped Nazi Germany
wrote about the origins of
totalitarianism in 1951.
About fascism, about Stalinism.
She says, the goal of totalitarianism
is to see that the victim
never existed at all.
And very hauntingly
quotes a survivor who says
when no witnesses are left,
there can be no testimony.
Well, witness means to know.
Someone who witnesses things, knows them.
He or she experienced something.
It's not just ocular,
not just that you saw it,
but that you experienced it.
You went through something.
And to testify is to
bring knowledge to others.
It's to attest, it's to bear witness,
it's to provide evidence and proof.
I saw this, this happened,
I was there and this is what happened.
So to destroy those things
is to destroy knowledge.
This is the last months of the liquidation
of the Warsaw ghetto in 1943,
before these people were
shipped out to Treblinka
where they're almost all gassed.
In the archive that was
created in the Warsaw ghetto
a man named Emanuel
Ringelblum, a historian,
decided to collect documents
of what people were experiencing
in these horrific years of 1941, '42, '43.
And he decided to know
about everyday life.
What were people experiencing?
He wrote, not a single
fact should be omitted.
Let the world read and know
what the murderers have done.
What did they do with the archive?
They buried it.
They buried it in the ground,
deep in the ground in metal boxes.
After the war, three people survived
who know about where this archive was.
They dug it up in 1946 and 1951.
Only parts of it, part of it's been lost.
It was in milk crates,
it was in metal boxes.
And what was inside were
testimonies of people
who were themselves killed.
These were their last words.
These were wills, these were
letters, these were sermons,
these were newspaper clippings,
they were reports in multiple languages.
But it was knowledge meant
to be shipped to the future.
Shipped out of the Warsaw ghetto.
And it was so precarious
because what's the chances
that anyone would survive to
actually know where it was
to dig it up and then to
recognize it as knowledge
and say, this is important,
it's worth preserving.
I've been interested in this concept
of sending messages to the
future for a long time.
And I'm particularly struck by the idea
of putting a message in a bottle.
Like, why would you put
a message in a bottle?
Like, where are you sending it to,
especially if you don't know
you're ever gonna survive?
A woman from Ravensbruck, a
women's concentration camp
who made art and buried it in a bottle
that was only dug up years later.
Or a sketchbook,
amazingly, from Auschwitz.
Found in a bottle in 1947.
We don't have photographs from Auschwitz.
We have these sketches, we
don't know who made them.
We'd have no idea, they're not signed.
And yet, they bear witness
to people being exterminated
almost in a photographic-like way.
I'm haunted to think more, as
I think about this question,
I've been thinking a
lot more comparatively
beyond my field of Holocaust
and genocide studies,
and begin to think about
what messages in bottles
have never been found?
What about that other milk
crate that was also buried
in the Warsaw ghetto?
It's never been found.
We don't know where it is.
What messages and what
knowledge, what witnesses,
what lives are contained in it?
Well, think about it this way.
This is the history of slavery
told through slave ships.
What you see running there
is an amazing database
presented by a number of collaborators
across the world, at Emory University
detailing slave ships coming
from West Coast of Africa
to the Americas, to Brazil, to Jamaica,
to Cuba, to North America.
It details hundreds of years.
Each dot is a slave ship.
Each dot represents somewhere
between 300 and 500 slaves.
Where are their messages, their voices?
Who bears witness to them?
How do we begin to excavate
the submerged knowledge?
This question, to me,
is a very profound one
as we begin to think about
the historical record.
Most of the time what we
have in the historical record
are the documents of the perpetrators.
We have the documents
of the legal decisions
about particular things that happened.
We have the charters of the ships,
we have the records of
how many slaves were taken
how many died in the Middle
Passage and how many arrived
and where they were enslaved.
We have their ages, we have their gender.
We often don't even have their names.
This particular report is very important
because it's the Zong slave ship
which, the owners of the ship,
in the course of the journey
threw overboard 150 slaves
and then decided that
they had lost their cargo
and made a claim against their
insurers to be compensated.
The only record of this
is the historical record
the legal documents that
was produced in this debate.
We know nothing of the people.
Again, submerged voices,
submerged witnesses.
Toni Morrison, I think, is
someone who begins to think
about how literary and historical
knowledge can go together.
And one thinks about the
millions of people that she says,
disappear without a trace
because they never arrive safely onshore.
It's like a whole nation
that's under the sea.
Her approach is to think
about literary knowledge.
How does literary knowledge
complement historical knowledge?
How can literature, poetic thinking,
and ways of looking at the archive
bring a truth or shed a light
on people that were
destroyed, who have no voices?
Who had no archive?
She says only an act of the
imagination can help me.
Her idea of only an
act of the imagination,
this is not fictionalizing
in the sense of making it up.
But of adding to the historical record
in order to show the
silences that exist there.
My last example is a poet who makes use
particularly of the Zong
case, NourbeSe Philip.
Extraordinary book of
poems that came out in 2007
where she takes that legal
report that I showed you earlier
this report, here, and
takes apart the words
pries apart the language
in order to look for
not only the ways in which
language is connected to power
but also those voices, the
people that have been left out.
She says in here, it's
really quite amazing,
it's a reference.
Our fellow creatures may
become the subject of property.
This, therefore, was a
throwing overboard of goods
and part of it was to save the residue.
Why they threw the slaves overboard.
They were essentially goods, like wood
is what that report says.
She takes these words and rewrites them.
She takes them, they kind of are submerged
some of them come forward,
some come backwards,
some of them are rewritten.
But in every case, it's
to bring poetic knowledge
to show the absences in
the historical record.
I'll leave you with a
quote from NourbeSe Philip
because I think it's so telling.
There's no telling the story.
In fact, the story can't be recovered.
But it must be told.
There's paradox, right, there's tension
of it can't be told, it must be told.
Zong, her book about this
slave ship, bears witness
to the resurfacing of the
drowned and the oppressed.
Transform this desiccated, legal report
into a cacophony of voices,
wails, cries, moans and shouts
that had earlier been
banned from the text.
This, I think, is really the
ethical stakes of knowledge.
Thank you.
(audience applauds)
- Thanks, Todd.
Thank you, Todd.
Thanks so much, everybody,
Marcelo Suarez-Orozco.
- Thank you so much, thank you.
Thank you, Brett for inviting me
and thank you to my
colleagues here at the stage
and my colleagues in the audience
and I look forward really
more to the conversation.
I have a few reflections
that flow from the work of our colleagues.
I just wanna enumerate them in order.
Brett, you started us with knowledge
and its unique attributes.
I was thinking as you were speaking
that perhaps what is uniquely
human is the accumulation
and the accumulated
transmission of knowledge
as perhaps one of the
uniquely human attributes.
We don't have to reinvent
the grammar of the French language.
Once it's articulated
it has a life that is transgenerational.
So the accumulation of knowledge,
we'll get to the question of what that is,
may be a uniquely human attribute.
I think perhaps another
uniquely human capacity
I was reflecting upon
your comments, Brett,
had to do with your reflection on
how do we know that we know something?
And that of course speaks to something
that may be the jewel in crown.
What cognitive neuroscientists
call the metacognitive.
The so-called executive function
of the central nervous system.
This, again, may be uniquely
human capacity to reflect upon
our knowing.
The so-called metacognitive architecture
that is so much a part of
who we are as a species.
Victoria, your work with
the body, it's so amazing.
And of course, the body knows.
Pascal has a beautiful line when he says,
and I think he means more
broadly, he has a line,
the heart knows a reason for
which reason has no reason.
There are ways the body
knows that our other that
the binary logic of the
Cartesian sort-of world
of mind and body, culture, nature.
So, I applaud you for reminding us
how much of the human
experience and human evolution
is the work the body does
in terms of our orientation to the world.
Todd, of course, I was very
moved by your reflections
and this, I think, is why acknowledgement
and the politics of acknowledgement
becomes so central to the endeavors
to heal the extraordinary damage
human beings can do to each other.
And think of the Truth and
Reconciliation committees
in South Africa, in Latin America,
in so many parts of the
world, where, of course.
Elaine Scarry has a beautiful line
in her book The Body in Pain on torture.
She says, of course, in torture,
the pain can't be represented.
We don't have language, it is unknowable,
the pain of others.
Not unlike what Adorno said
about the truth is buried in the ashes.
We can endeavor to excavate
it but it's a very incomplete
and very imperfect.
So knowledge and
acknowledgement are so central
to the work of suffering
in the human condition.
So these are some
reflections to my comments
to my colleagues in the
spirit of conversation.
So, knowledge, knowledge, how do we know?
I'll start, wear my hat here
as the Dean of the Graduate School
of Education and
Information Studies at UCLA
and I'll start with the following claim
that knowledge is dangerous
and proceed with caution
when you're dealing with knowledge.
But let me make this claim.
It is a fundamental pillar of,
let's put it very broadly, civilization.
The great H. G. Wells, 150 years ago, said
history now is a race between
education and catastrophe.
Well, if you know something,
you know who's winning that race today.
(audience laughs)
Knowledge is a fundamental pillar
of democracy, of civilization.
This is why the great John Dewey,
in his book Democracy and Education,
puts education, puts the knowing citizen
at the center of the work of democracy.
And prophetically, Dewey
says, the work of democracy
is the work that each
generation needs to renew.
And it's renewed through,
in his wisdom, education.
His main argument is education is not
a preparation for life.
Education is life, and democracy lives
in the work education does for all of us.
So this is sort of the first
broad claim about knowledge.
A pillar for, especially,
again, as Brett got us started,
in the current world where
knowledge and facts and reality
are contested in the most
savage, sort of fundamental ways
where language is kidnapped from us
and all the shared understandings
that are fundamental
to the work of knowledge are ephemeral.
Now, more formally, when
we think about knowledge
of course, and this is something
that Victoria articulated
for us, we think in terms of
knowledge is cognition, knowledge.
(speaking in foreign language)
These are all cognate words.
And they flow from two separate
sort of very basic constitutive units.
One is experience and familiarity.
The habits that the body knows
often better than the mind.
This is what the great William James
called experience near knowledge.
The knowledge that comes from the habit.
Knowledge is a cognate
word of familiarity also.
Is that which comes to
us as a way of knowing
that is familiar, that
we are at ease with.
So that's one of the ways
of entering an approach to knowledge.
What I think you called natural knowing.
Of course, we are in the university,
and the university is in the
business of what we will call
ways of knowing that are organized
and they tend to be organized
into the disciplines.
We had a brilliant discussion by Todd
that very much flows from the architecture
of a set of disciplinary understandings
that are shared, they're common,
they're habits that we form.
And in a university,
knowledge tends to live
in disciplinary habitats.
We have historical ways of knowing.
Geographical ways of knowing.
Philosophical ways of knowing.
Architectural ways of
knowing, and the like.
Immediately, something very
fascinating begins to happen
which is, there is a reason why
knowledge over the centuries
became organized around systems
that we come to call disciplines.
And that is, what happens
where the disciplines come to converse?
What happens when, before
I joined the dark side
and I became an administrator,
I was a regular academic.
I was a regular scholar
who did regular research
and wrote regular books and articles.
And that lives very much
within disciplinary traditions.
But what's very interesting today,
and I think it's been
very interesting really
since the beginning of the
organization of disciplines
is the idea of interdisciplinary work.
Work that spills over
and can't be contained.
And the work that
interdisciplinarity does for us
is in many ways comes full circle
to the issue of familiarity.
Because interdisciplinary
work fundamentally interrupts
the taken for granted, familial practices
that come to colonize disciplinary work.
If you're a psychologist,
psychologists have a handshake.
I've been married to a
psychologist for 42 years.
I think finally I discovered
what their secret handshake is.
They have secret rituals,
they have secret knowledge.
They practice their discourse
in very exotic journals.
(audience laughs)
They read each other's journals.
It's almost like the secret societies
of the Ourunta or Orunda.
And what's very fascinating
is the approach and avoidance
that comes with our endeavors
to work within disciplinary
bodies of knowledge,
ways of knowing and the
kinds of disruptions
that come with a conversation
between disciplines.
I'm gonna take three minutes to show you
representations of a domain of scholarship
which is the area of
work where I'm engaged in
which is the study of the
mass movements of people.
And what I'd like to show
you is representations.
These are bodies of knowledge
that have become instantly recognized.
This is something that every
demographer in the galaxy
including the ones they're
gonna find in Mars now
will recognize immediately
as a body of knowledge
about, this is the world,
and this is where people originate.
Three or four issues that
dominate the movement of people
in the 21st century.
All continents are
involved in sending people,
what we call emigration, transit,
immigration and return migration.
So here you have the world as represented.
It's a bit orderly, more obvious
for you to sort of reflect upon
what's going on in the world.
Asia is the epicenter of
the movement of people.
everything in the 21st century.
So, I you think you have a
caravan coming to your country
that's not really where the action is.
(audience laughs)
I hate to tell you,
you can Tweet that one.
That's not where the action.
Maybe you know who, Caligula
could respond to that.
And this is another representation.
This falls very much
within the domain of the social sciences.
This to me represents why people migrate.
My definition of migration
is an ethical act
of and for the family,
and it's love and work.
It's a migration, it's an
act of love for the family
and so love and work are the
main drivers of migration.
I think that this, in a way, captures,
as a kind of, this is monumental art,
this is a beautiful sculptural
representation of that.
And this, to me, represents
the problematique
of the 21st century.
This is, do we know what this it?
(audience murmuring)
What is this?
- The Guernica.
What is Guernica?
- War.
- Anti-war painting.
- The Spanish Civil War, the Guernica.
This is a Picasso.
Where did it hang?
This hang in the U.N. for many years
until Franco died, because Picasso
wouldn't let it be back in Spain.
Now it's in the Reina Sofia.
It's very spectacular.
And here we bear witness
to war and terror.
This is what's driving the
movement of people today.
If you don't understand what's
going on miles from here.
The people are escaping war
and terror and environmental collapse.
So the Guernica, to me,
really the most fundamental representation
as a kind of a bear witness
of the horror of war.
Todd, Franco allowed
Luftwaffe, the German air force
to bomb Guernica.
Franco was Galician, and
Guernica's in the Basque Country.
Orozco's a Basque name, I'm
Basque, I'm part Basque.
And he allowed the Germans
to do practice runs.
So this was just practice,
this wasn't real war.
So this was the destruction of
a town, the town of Guernica.
And of course it has the
horror and representability
this unspeakable of the horror of the war.
The bull, of course,
is us, is the witness.
Because we need to bear
witness to the destruction
that human beings are capable.
We are wolf, man is wolf to man,
is a line in Hobbes I think in essay.
So these, in a way, give you
a kind of artistic representations
of the movements of people.
Why people have to leave,
why people come to new destinations.
And this falls more within the
realm of the social sciences
the demographics, cultural geography
and the disciplines that
are so well represented
in the scholarly study of
the mass movements of people.
Ways of knowing are incomplete.
Ways of knowing are in fundamental ways
deconstructed and reconstructed.
And it is fundamentally
impossible to separate
broadly speaking what we call
the scientific ways of knowing
and the artistic ways of knowing,
the humanistic ways of knowing.
And I think that these
representations of knowledge
about this very defining
issue in our world today
tell the story of the
partial ways we endeavor
to through knowledge approximate
and model the world we live in,
our experiences as a species
and our ambitions as a
moral creature in the world.
Thank you.
(audience applauds)
- Thank you, Marcelo.
Marcelo, thank you so much.
And our final presentation,
Kristy Edmunds.
- Okay, wow.
I just gotta say that, right now.
Wow, wow, triple wow.
A few things in terms
of my ways of knowing
is that I'm going to throw
out a lot of what it was
that I thought I was going to say.
(audience laughs)
So that I can connect a way of
knowing what I'm experiencing
to what you might be experiencing.
So, I just wanna talk to the students
and obviously the public a little bit.
But let me ask a few sequenced
kind of questions, okay?
You can raise your hands, these
are kind of bifurcated or's.
Information or facts?
Information, hands up.
That you value more.
Facts.
Facts or data?
Data.
Oh, data's pulling ahead.
Information or experience?
Information.
Experience.
Do you guys love this, aren't I a genius?
(audience laughs)
Knowledge or skills?
Knowledge.
Skills.
Skills or wisdom?
Skills, wisdom, how are
y'all gonna get there?
Perception or knowledge?
Perception.
Knowledge.
Knowledge or wisdom?
Wisdom.
Wisdom wins again.
Food or air?
(audience laughs)
Food.
Air.
Okay.
High levels of interdependency
across all that terminology.
Right?
Total, utter interdependency.
How data might move to information,
and information to
fictions, fictions to facts,
fictions to consciousness,
fictions to lies,
lies to truths, truths to knowledge.
Whose knowledge, whose truth, whose lie?
Et cetera, et cetera, et cetera, right?
So everything that we were talking about
around what is experienced.
Lived experienced is a body of knowledge
that lives in our body
through every sensory apparatus
that we possibly have.
So when I was first
thinking about how do I,
I haven't even talked about
what I do, I'm sorry about that.
Part of what I've been thinking about
amongst the true and utter
challenge of trying to figure out
how to, do you define
it, do you explore it,
do you noodle with it.
I've been doing all that for weeks.
But to me, one of the the things
that's really critically,
critically, critically important
is what you guys just did.
You put your hands up by the mass majority
around the idea of wisdom
as the thing you value most.
And yet, human history,
as has been demonstrated
here by quite a bit,
my question is often, not
so much what is knowledge
but what is it that we do with it.
And in the doing of
that is all other kinds
of other words in the vernacular
and so on and so forth.
What we do with it and
what we hope to do with it
probably has some leaning
towards how do we acquire wisdom.
Wisdom through knowledge and consciousness
and the body and the mind
and every other interdependent
system that we possibly have
is utterly, utterly, utterly independent.
And consciousness to me is
one of the single pieces
of what I do professionally
with working with artists as a curator.
So I wanted to just back up quickly
because I've been thinking of this project
and this topic and this discussion.
For me, I think about,
what is the knowledge
that I have, because it was gifted?
And a gift can be learned
or earned, but it's a gift.
An education, benevolent, infrastructure.
So on and so forth, the people,
the family, the influencers.
Et cetera, et cetera.
What is the knowledge that
I have that was given to me?
Someone cared enough to
transmit that knowledge.
What is the knowledge that
I sought out and found?
What did I pursue to know?
Which is something else
in another kind of way.
And what is the knowledge that I now have
that's even worth passing on?
What will I transmit?
I have to say, honestly,
that as a curator and artistic director,
I have worked, I have probably
learned not everything
I don't want to make a
sweeping generalization,
but I have probably learned
almost everything that I know
through the avenues of the arts.
From very early age, with
my mother, my grandmother,
various other people, all the way up.
And the reason is because in the arts
the outcomes are unknown,
they're not locked and fixed
and the burning thing that runs across it
is a passionate life that
is seeking to find form
and continuously asking
certain kinds of questions.
The question that I think, no
matter what discipline it is
whatever, whether it's
visual, practice, cinema,
whether it's design media,
choreography, theater,
storytelling, poetry,
et cetera, et cetera.
The question that an artist asks
and logs gazillions of hours in the asking
is a question of whereto from here?
How to proceed, how best to proceed.
At a micro level, how
do I cross the stage.
Whereto from here in
a choreographic realm,
in time and space.
In theater, what line next?
What words next?
In writing, the pen on the
page, whereto from here?
Architecture, et cetera, et cetera.
The question is asked,
the question is practiced.
And it leads to a body of knowledge
that continuously opens the
door for more questions.
And of course artists
are involved quite deeply
in the question at a very
small, molecular level
like I was describing.
But it's also a question
that is very meta about us.
Whereto from here?
How best to proceed?
How to proceed?
In what form, in what way?
And my job as a curator is
literally to work with artists
in all different mediums
where their imaginative,
passionate, and hyper-knowledgeable
mind/body/soul/spirit
consciousness is asking
a bunch of these questions.
And I'm entrusted with it
at it's most vulnerable.
The trust piece is an acknowledgement,
acknowledge, knowledge.
The trust piece is how do
I share a vulnerable idea
in order to get it out there in a way
that others can co-mingle
and collaborate with it,
amplify, push me in different
kinds of directions,
and then find form, et
cetera, et cetera, et cetera.
So, to me, almost every
form of artistic knowledge
that I've ever encountered
is the knowledge proposition
around knowledge exchanged as a gift.
And that the gift in a society
is something that forces us
also in this era know
a lot about economics.
Right, shall we say?
Artists, because the
outcome is not always known,
it can't always be collected,
it can't be turned into a commodity.
Art is a gift, that artists
who endeavor to make it,
are utilizing every
system sensory knowledge
plus training, plus
skill, plus, plus, plus
to find an avenue through which
to keep the potency of that
knowledge, a.k.a. a gift,
whether it's signs or symbols
or whatever, in motion.
Because when we keep our gift in motion
it continues to accrue power.
So I have a quick story that
I want to describe to you
because I think it goes partially
to why I work in this particular way
and then I'll wrap it up.
And I have to kind of read
my sequences through it
but it has to do with.
How many of you know in
Native Plains-related,
Lakota, Nokota, Dakota,
Native American
traditions, the peace pipe?
Do you know what it is?
Okay, so a peace pipe,
in its raw materials
is not a super elaborate thing.
But what its job is, inside of a tribe,
is that it's bestowed to a Chief.
And the Chief, in the
tradition, holds the peace pipe
and in that peace pipe, it's brought out
at the most significant moments,
conflicts and difficulties
across the tribal system.
It is a point of reference,
stories are told,
music is played, song lines
are song, et cetera, et cetera.
And the peace pipe being present
is imbued with cultural knowledge.
The person who protects
that knowledge is the Chief
because the knowledge has
to then be retained, shared,
and it's imbued in a person
who has the discernment
and consciousness and capacity to care
for more than themselves
to carry that through.
And it's passed across
generation to generation,
generation, generation down the line.
So at the point that
knowledge, in this case,
living in this pipe, gets
changed fundamentally
and permanently from what it is
is the moment that another
system comes towards it
in this case, they system
of commodity, and it's sold.
Those peace pipes, in different tribes,
were eventually sold for
access to reservation land
without death after carnage.
But this is the kind of gift
that you can only sell one time
because after that, it loses
all of its knowledge power,
its cultural trust and
what it's imbued to do
across generational time.
It becomes a commodity and from that point
the raw materials later
on, in a commodity market,
mean that the Native people
will make a whole bunch
of small peace pipes
and sell them through a commodity
at the market, at the blanket,
at the trinket hawking of the wares.
The monetary system takes
over the gift system
in this instance.
And the knowledge exchange is denied
to the person of the
acquisition through money
from the person who
actually carries wisdom.
But there's a cultural reality also
in terms of what I was
describing around the arts.
And this is why I work in it.
If an artist decides to
take that peace pipe now
and imbue it with the aesthetic integrity
of finding form and meaning and value
and labors with skill and intentionality
and care and imaginative
realms, and manifests that now
disconnected from its original history
it now accrues again the
knowledge, again the possibility
and again the value of becoming a gift.
A gift that from that point
forward stays in motion
in service to cultural knowledge.
The arts are a cultural
asset and resource.
And how we exchange our
knowledge can be provoking
can be widely, widely received.
It can be experimental and contortionist
and it can be a variety of other things.
But what it says is,
the vulnerability of
my pursuits in thought
and idea and knowledge
I seek to manifest in the form of a gift
that it will awaken a
perceptional capacity
within your knowledge and
therefore we collaborate.
Thank you.
(audience applauds)
- Thank you.
Thank you, and all four of you,
thank you so much for those presentations.
I think as Vic suggested at the beginning
let's stand up, take 90 seconds,
if you want to jump around
and shake it out for a minute
lean over to a neighbor, do that.
We'll do the same up here
and we'll be back online
in about a minute and a half.
Thank you everybody so much.
Those were just such terrific,
terrific presentations
each on their own.
I think I want to first
turn to the four of you.
Having listened now to
the other three are there,
what I really appreciate
is the extent to which
you were acknowledging and aware of things
already being spoken of
here on the sofa and stage.
Now standing back from
it a few minutes later
any thoughts about unexpected convergence,
coincidence, or ignorance of ideas
beyond the ones you might
have been thinking about?
Any thought?
- Well, maybe I could jump in with.
I started to say this to you a moment ago.
There seems to be a convergence
or an opportunity for us to think about
education and the university
and this notion of a gift.
So on the one hand,
while we're a land-grant
public university,
we have a tuition, students
have tuition that they pay
in order to learn, in order
to have access to knowledge.
But on the other hand,
this passage of knowledge
this sort of firmly-held beliefs
in the value of what we
have learned is a gift.
And I think oftentimes
it's given as a gift.
So I wonder if we could
just talk a little bit about
the balance between education
becoming a commodity
and education as a gift.
And I think that probably
you all have a lot to say about this too
but maybe we could start up here.
- Who has to start?
(laughing)
- Okay, ladies first.
I often think and reflect
on the fact of education
me through, my mother was born
on the Indian reservation,
I was born not far from there.
The kind of ability to climb
and do different kinds of things
and have facility or
flexibility or fluidity
in a broader world due to
education, public education.
So for me, I always think
of it from the perspective
of an infrastructure that
was put into practice
that it means that future generations.
I'm cognizant of the fact that someone
or a series of someones
took a benevolent interest
in the fact that I would
have access to an education.
I am also the kind of person who thinks
when I'm driving on roads of the people
who worked their asses
off to build these things
in the hot sun, et cetera, et cetera.
I think of these shared
spaces and I think of them.
Hugely, the consciousness to acknowledge
that the efforts, the
knowledge, the skills, the labor
the practices of others
make a framework possible
for how I am able to stand within.
And that, to me, is the gift of education,
in a certain kind of way.
And the warning in it
is that we feel possibly
only thinking of its value
in terms of what the
investment monetarily is.
And that piece is a
deep, deep provocation.
If an educational system turns itself
into a commodity-based market,
then the gift of the sense
of public intellectualism
and sharing and stretching and striving,
having your soul stretched,
your life stretched,
your means stretched, changes.
It's the same working in the arts.
When people will say, please
curate and put on stage
that which is most popular so
that the tickets will sell out
so that there will be a resource
platform inside of there
which isn't looking at the
scholarship of the form
or things like that.
It's like, I have Sweet Honey in the Rock
in the house at Royce Hall right now.
They're rehearsing, they're vocalizing,
they've been through the
Civil Rights Movement,
they're the soundtrack of an entire set
of multiple generations.
They are not there for the paycheck.
The paycheck is a resource
that keeps the gift of
their song in motion
so that they can do the deep work
of continuing to provoke the
song lines of civil rights,
how they merge with hip hop now,
and how they, as a group of women,
stand in the power of their bodies
to make meaning manifest amongst strangers
so that we have collaborative lines
of relationship with on another
in secular time and space.
That's part of an education here.
Okay, I talked long enough.
- If I may, Victoria,
think your invitation
is a very good point of entry
into the models that flow
from the logic of the market
which really fundamentally forms consumers
to the ethic of the gift, the
ethic of giving and receiving
of forming that is what
animates the work of education
and the work of knowledge.
So you have very different points of entry
and very different destinations
when the logic of the market
becomes the driver of how
we think about education.
The work of education, this
is why I started with Dewey,
is really the work of citizenship.
When the Greeks first imagined
what we know would recognize
as formal education systems
it's very fascinating because
the nexus to the market
and to the labor force was
very low in the thinking
of what are the purposes of education.
The Greeks imagine
education in the context
of the idea of the eudaimonic flourishing
of human potential to
its maximum capacity.
In the formative moment,
when education becomes a public good
when societies arrive at the
moment where public education
becomes a normative ideal the world over
the spirit animating that movement
was the spirit of
citizens, of citizenship.
And it was in fact, in the context
of the last previous
wave of mass migration,
when public education became
an instrument of the state
to create shared experiences,
to create common bonds in the citizens
that were arriving in our case.
And we can talk about Germany
as a different sort of model.
But in a society of consent,
like the United States,
what do we have in common?
And then it's education, it's citizenship,
it's the point of entry
into the public sphere.
And it's interesting that in the moment
when public education
becomes a normative idea the world over
the fundamental debates
where driven by philosophical
claims on our limits.
In Europe, Durkheim became the
first professor of pedagogy.
- [Kristy] You're gonna have to get him
on next week's thing,
what is a university.
- The first professor of
pedagogy is Emile Durkheim
who is maybe one of the fathers
certainly of French sociology,
sociology more broadly.
If you look at the
evolution, and in our country
it was, of course, James, Dewey.
In Italy, it was Maria Montessori.
In South America was
the great Paulo Freire.
The idea was the nexus between
the individual and society.
This is Durkheim's famous formulation.
50 years, you fast-forward,
this is 100, 150 years ago, I think.
Durkheim takes a chair in
pedagogy, I think at Bordeaux,
maybe in Paris, I can't remember now.
And he becomes the first
professor of pedagogy
in the world, really.
In this second fundamental
moment in the idea
of public education,
it's all the cognitive psychologist
and the cognitive revolution.
It's Jerry Burner and his students.
Howard Gardner, so many others.
Today, the logic of the
market has completely invaded
how we think about education.
Economists are all of a
sudden the grand seers
of what is an education worth
pursuing or worth supporting
for a democracy.
This would have been incomprehensible
in the formative moment
when so much of the basic
questions about education
were about the good society
were about citizenship,
were about empathy, were
about the common good.
Not about, how do we
extract value from labor.
- Well, it's interesting
that you mentioned in passing
Paulo Freire and Pedagogy
of the Oppressed.
Of course, this is another avenue
where you have an opportunity
to think of an educational system
that's very much not top-down or driven
by that kind of master model
which is there in the history of pedagogy.
Even the term pedagogue is
a master who led children.
That was where it came from.
This of course changed over
time, and thankfully so.
But it had a sense of
hierarchical, you know,
you had knowledge, it was passed down.
Pedagogy of the Oppressed
was really inverting that
in very fundamental ways
and creating a much broader
community of practitioners
and participants in a
kind of dialogical, open
and obviously dialectically inflected way.
He's very much inflected
by Hegel and Marx.
And that was the basic of the critique
which again brings in
the critique of capital
and the critique of capitalism
and those who have and
wield power in various ways.
So I think this is an avenue,
to me, that we wanna reclaim,
That we really wanna prioritize
when we think about
education is that tradition
that I think Freire and really going back
probably to Marx also
really brought to the fore.
The other thing I wanted to respond to.
The German tradition is interesting, too,
because the word for education there is.
(speaks in foreign language)
It comes from sculpture,
which means you can turn,
you can make something.
It also has a sense of image.
You can be like in the image of God,
because that was one
way to think about it.
But it was also a sense of
formation or creation or making.
But you really have a sense
of artistic practice there
and it's very much open-ended.
It didn't necessarily lead
in one particular direction.
And when the German universities
in the early 19th century were founded,
I'm kind of thinking in
terms of Humboldt and others
and this idea of liberal education.
This became important
to the United States.
This was really a tradition that was
of the multi-sided education
of the human being.
Disciplines were not meant to be silos
but were meant to be traversed.
And education was really holistic.
It was about thinking about
the human being as a whole.
So, to be educated is also to be formed
and form is never teleological.
- The other inversion, Todd, is of course
Maria Montessori and Christina
Rinaldi of Reggio Children
where the child is the point of entry
into teaching and learning.
It's who's teaching whom.
- Exactly.
- We were in Erice recently, in Sicily.
And Christina Rinaldi, who
is runs the Reggio Children,
these are the best preschools in the world
starts with, so who is
teaching who here? (chuckles)
And of course, Montessori,
Rinaldi, so many others
the moment you put the child
at the center of teaching and learning
you have a radically different idea
that inverts this hierarchical
story that we know so well
in education.
- I'm gonna open the
conversation to the floor
in just a moment.
As a transition to that, one
thing I'm really struck by
across the four presentations
is that a sense of responsibility
brought very close to bear
on any idea of knowledge
that we might contemplate.
And I guess an obvious
question for each of you
or any of you that might want
to take a stab at it would be
who do you feel most responsible to
in thinking about your own work
and thinking and performance
or scholarship or participation
as a producer, understander,
communicator of knowledge today?
Where does the responsibility
lie in your own thinking
in the work you do?
Is it to your peers, is
it to your audiences?
Is it to yourself, is it to
a larger category of being?
- Okay, I'll give it a try.
I couldn't say that there would be one.
I think that there are constantly
multiple spheres of responsibility.
Of course, I don't feel
responsible to myself
I simply feel passionately
engaged with learning more.
I feel responsible to all
the people who work with me
in the process of creating something.
In fact, that process sometimes becomes
the most important thing.
And I feel fascinated by the
process and responsibility
of what happens to this thing that I make
when it enters the world,
when it becomes something
that for a few moments
can be engaged by others.
That's my try.
- And it's a responsibility.
What I find most gratifying
is, I write about immigration,
when I give a talk and a young
person comes and tells me
yes, this speaks authentically
to my experience.
I feel that is maybe the
most gratifying space
for me to be in, when
somebody, a young person often,
says, you know, this tells my story.
To me, there's nothing greater
than that faithful
representation of the voices,
the dreams, the ambitions, the anxieties
of people that teach me.
Remember, I'm an anthropologist.
And in anthropology,
the only right you have
is the right to be
ignorant about the people.
As the great Cliff Geertz said,
knowledge is local knowledge.
It lives with your colleagues
and the endeavor becomes
constructing a set of understanding
that is faithful to the
experience of your collaborators.
- It's a question I
wrestle with constantly.
And I feel that there's
an ethical dimension
in the work that I try to do
and I also am conscious of my failures
to be able to take on that responsibility.
And I mean that by, I have a voice
and I have a certain amount of
privilege that comes with it.
In various domains,
whether it's being male
or able-bodied, Caucasian.
And I think that there's an obligation
to understand and be
critical of that privilege
but also what it means to stand open
and be willing to listen to voices
that don't have the same
opportunities for amplification.
And that's where the
responsibility comes from
when I'm thinking about the archive
or these voices that I was mentioning.
You become kind of a
steward for knowledge.
A possible conduit,
but also one who can refract
it in different ways.
But knowing that you're also extremely,
it's a very precarious position.
And you have to ask yourself,
I ask myself constantly
what responsibility comes with that.
- [Brett] Thank you.
- Yeah, I love that.
For me, similarly,
responsibility, privilege
all these different kinds of things.
I can look it on the one hand
as a human being walking
around in the world
and I can say that, you
know, my kids, my mother.
My mother died this summer,
my kids are in growth.
The bodies of knowledge that
I have did not prepare me
for either of those things.
And yet somehow I am able
to draw from something
that came to me from
somewhere, et cetera, et cetera
to navigate those points
where you do have to flip
towards wisdom and rely
deeply on ignorance.
And the lack of knowing in a blind way
doesn't absolve you of
responsibility to care.
So I think of it in that term.
When I think of it territorially speaking
which is a similar kind of thing.
From Freire, to care enough,
to care for the thing.
And that is a job description
in my humble opinion.
The rest are just are just
acronyms and business cards
and things, but that's a job description.
When I think of it, I think of it
through the eyes, often,
of a theater director,
a profound theater
director, Ariane Mnouchkine
She's based outside of Paris.
I asked her one time how
she prepares the cast
to perform the work for
like the 300th, 400th time
with such intensity, because
of the subject matter
that they deal with often in the work.
And they get together beforehand
and stand in a kind of
huddle and she says to them
tonight there will be
someone in the theater
who has never been here,
we perform for that person.
Tonight is also a person
that will be the last time
they're in a theater, we
perform for that person.
My sense of responsibility is
the belief in that potential.
- Terrific, thank you, amazing you all.
Let's turn it and open
it up to the floor here.
I've got, just to start.
Our TAs have got microphones
with some of the students,
let's begin there.
Kyle, you've got someone
here, yeah, please.
- Hello, thank you all for
coming tonight and presenting.
All the presentations were amazing.
My question is, how do
instructors or institutions
determine what is better
for students to learn
and what is the process that goes behind
what knowledge is best
passed to the students?
And this is for everyone.
- [Todd] I'm gonna leave
that to the academics.
(panel chuckles)
- So as a Dean I would say the following,
which is this really
lives with the faculty
and the autonomy of the faculty
and the faculty's judgment as pertinent
to the very thoughtful and
thorough question you posed.
So really, there is a ways in which
the disciplines organize themselves.
The individual faculty members
have a great deal of latitude
as to how to engage in the
endeavor of teaching and learning
and the working with students.
So there's a great deal of autonomy.
While, I think, the disciplines
hold a very important space
in how teaching and
learning are organized,
ultimately, faculty members
really have the autonomy and the range
to actualize those general
principles in the classroom.
- I think when I decide
what knowledge should be passed forward,
like to say, when I put
a syllabus together,
I made some decisions as
to what we're gonna read
and what we're not gonna read
and what we're gonna watch
or not watch, if it's a film.
And those decisions are always,
you question them constantly.
It's not that you do this one time.
It's constantly asking
yourself what knowledge
should be practiced or passed forward.
For me, I'm interested in texts
or documents that will haunt
that will stay with you as you grow
and that you'll come
back to in different ways
because they mean things,
perhaps differently,
as you encounter them at
different points in your life.
And I often select things
that that's happened to me.
So I may have read something when I was 20
and when I'm 40, I'm gonna
read it quite differently
and I imagine when I'm 60
I'll read it again differently
and that's actually part of the point
because it speaks of the process of growth
that I go through and
that you will go through.
Nothing is static.
Who you are is constantly
changing and evolving.
The language you're using.
I don't mean just the
language you're speaking
although I do mean that.
But I also mean the expressiveness
and the way we encounter a text.
And it doesn't have to
be written, of course.
It can be performed.
These things all change.
And so I'm interested
that'll haunt us though
and in things that we'll have
to reckon with more than once.
- Thank you.
Over on this side, Gigi or Anna,
do we have someone on that side?
- There's someone right there.
- Where, I'm sorry, I'm looking,
oh yes, right here, please.
- It's on.
- Sorry, okay.
Hi and thank you all again.
My question is, if knowledge
is as valuable and scarce
as we've been taught,
why does society push
education on everyone?
Wouldn't that take away from
the quality of knowledge itself
or is it that we're only
subject to limited truths
and the full lengths of
information should be protected?
- Thank you.
- So, knowledge is imperfect
and it's in perpetual change.
There's also such thing as progress.
Meaning the fact that more
people become educated
and more people are familiar,
to go back to Victoria's point of entry,
makes for a more democratic society
where more voices in the
citizenry can weigh in
on the issues of the day.
The pursuit of knowledge
is eternal because
knowledge is imperfect and incomplete.
Knowledge is never
extracting truth from facts
and from nature and from archives.
It's more like making sausage.
(audience laughs)
It's not so pretty up close.
And we make mistakes and we come back.
We accumulate knowledge.
We go past previous
traps, previous mistakes.
So it's a perpetual endeavor, it's never.
I think, and I told Franz,
that a work of art is never finished.
It's abandoned.
You can say the same about knowledge.
The pursuit of knowledge
is never finished.
Some of us abandon it earlier than others.
(audience laughs)
But it's something that you
have a career in politics
in some countries if you do that now.
Tragically, that's not meant to be funny.
(audience titters)
That's why it revisits
us in different ways
in different generations.
- I didn't fully, totally understand
the elements of the
question or I missed them
or they got left in the sea of response.
But I did have a response
that came to mind
that I think has some relational value
and that's, to me, when I
think of going to university
or the pursuit of an education,
there's the difference between
a pursuit of an education
in order to have a
certification at the end
and that certification at
the end brokers access points
to a particular working life
that leads, further tighten
up the screws of perfection,
towards expertise, right?
Really profound expertise.
And that's one thing.
There's also that place
where the encounter
with so much other gives
us a way of recognizing
elements of what makes us
feel awake to ourselves
in the world, which is significant.
To be pressured and stretched
in those places of choice
to me, is a really important piece of it.
Which can be that the path
of expertise is abandoned
in service to working
in a garden in the land
or doing something else that is ultimately
another kind of knowledge.
But how all those things are
interdependently knowable
to me comes through the
frameworks of a pursuit
and willingness to be educated.
- Thank you.
Right here in front.
And then we'll go over on the side, okay?
- Yeah it's on.
- No.
Okay, I wanted to ask you all
about the fundamental desire
the human desire for knowledge.
And what role you feel passion and desire
and love play in knowledge
and fundamentally our desire
to exchange knowledge.
- [Marcelo] We're Homo sapiens sapiens,
and there you have it.
(audience laughs)
- [Man] Because you guys talked about food
and air and I think sex, over here,
at the beginning you talked about it.
How does knowledge fit into that?
- [Kristy] Did she talk
about sex or horniness,
let's be clear?
(audience laughs)
- [Man] Oh, okay, sorry.
Carnal knowledge, I guess.
- [Marcelo] Carnal.
- I think that we have a continuous desire
not to say sexiness, to be in relationship
to engage our environment,
whatever that is.
And so I think that if knowledge
is continuously learning
how to converse with the
world and the people around us
at whatever scale that is
it seems like that curiosity
that inquiry come, as you say,
because we are part of the world.
I don't even want to
say because we're human.
- I think passion has a
great deal to do with it,
I think love, all of those things.
But really, in a certain kind of way,
if there's an openness
towards observation,
listening, and so on and so forth,
every sensory apparatus
that we have available to us
is going to make us fall towards knowing.
We will fall towards knowing
in one way or another.
And to me, it's that thing of when
you start to recognize that
your mind can start going
in all kinds of places, your
body, et cetera, et cetera.
But I think, I certainly know
when someone has a passion
to run out of the room
because the subject matter
that they're experiencing
is making them feel nuts.
My son is going through
that like madly now.
There's a passion to move away from things
and I think that's another
point of knowledge.
It's just utterly inevitable
that within the frameworks
of our belonging to life in our path
knowledge is gonna fall out of our sleeves
like notes on a page, you know?
What we do with it is a
different kind of animal.
Artistically speaking, I would say
that those bodies of knowledge
associated with artists
are utterly driven by passion
and a willingness to
stand in acknowledgement
of what is not known and
bypass a knowable outcome
in service to a possibility
that didn't exist without the pursuit.
That requires passion and
a variety of other things.
- Thank you, let's do one more question.
I see a microphone right
up here in the middle.
- First of all, I just
want to thank you guys
for your vulnerability as a panel.
I think the potential
that the five of you guys have created
by not cementing yourself in your fields
and being open to the
vulnerability of your fields
has been really awesome
for this discussion.
And I'm curious how you
perceive the word amateurism.
Amateur, to do something
for the love of it
and how that has been, you spoke about
by monetizing the peace pipe
it actually takes away the power of it.
As a part of this Millennial Generation,
how has amateurism been used
to keep people in their place
or in their lane, for
lack of a better term,
especially the youth
generation throughout history,
not just ours in the current moment?
- I would just ask, how is amateurism
a significant aspect of your experience?
I'm not sure what you mean.
- I think it seeps into a
lot of different fields.
It the arts, definitely,
also you can look at
amateur college athletics
and that not being monetized,
the billions of dollars that
are generated in that field
is kind of more specifically
where I'm coming from.
But I think the idea of amateurism, again,
going off the earlier question
of where love and doing
things for the love of it
has been kind of stripped.
You look at the rise of
B corporations, right.
There's this new business
model specifically designed
to say, we are a business
that actually cares
when however many years ago, historically,
that was just the natural component
of business and transaction
but now we've created an
actual, I don't know, yeah.
- In Spanish, what's the word for love?
(audience murmurs)
(speaks in a foreign language)
Amateurism, it's the love of.
- [Woman] That's what
I'm exactly getting at.
- It's the love of, and to me,
all knowledge is relational.
This is what 150 years
of cognitive-neuroscience
finally has discovered.
All knowledge is relational.
It flows from the magic
word that Victoria used
which is curiosity.
It's the wonder of being alive.
And it's the love of that
pursuit of understanding
what eventually becomes
codified into knowledge
that drives this perpetual
human capacity for knowing
for wanting to know, for acknowledging
and for the eternal magic
that comes with knowing
more about the fundamental
big, existential questions before us.
So love is at the center.
We did very fancy longitudinal
models of how kids learn
and it's relational.
That gets you the most for your buck
if we can use that
mercantilistic metaphor.
Kids learn in relationship.
I always walk into a school
and if the teachers are
rooting for the kids,
it's a good school.
It's a great school
when the kids are
rooting for the teachers.
Because that's true love.
And there's a brief letter
that is lost in the archives.
Albert Camus.
So he wins a Nobel
Prize, he's a young guy,
an Algerian immigrant in France.
His father's not around,
his mother is mute and deaf,
and he sits down, he wins a
Nobel Prize and he's in his 30s.
He wrote L'Etranger,
one of the great novels.
He sits down and writes
a letter to two people.
To his mother and to his teacher.
And that is a letter
of love to his teacher.
- I would just say, in
relation to amateurism,
for the love of.
Protect that place inside
of your march to greatness.
Utterly.
Because the tyranny of
expertise can be full of traps,
traps of exclusion, traps of unhappiness,
traps of a variety of things.
There's and artist that I
work with named Taylor Mac
and I'll just quote
him right here and now.
He would say, perfection is for assholes.
(audience laughs)
Okay, meaning, you're a little tight
on that expertise thing.
So, but that thing, if you think of it.
What is something that you know
that you wish you didn't know?
The likelihood is it would
be something very personal
in your experience.
What is something that you
know that you treasure knowing?
Is probably something
deeply personal in your experience, right?
What is something that you know
that you feel compelled to share
is probably something
that you were both taught
or gained extraordinary enjoyment from
that you want to pass on.
And what is the thing that
you have in your knowledge
that you want to share
purely for self advancement?
The crux between these
different intentions
to me, the amateur place
of how do we use our hand,
how do we use certain things,
how do you derive both
pleasure and meaning
from self discovery, self
manifestation of a hobby.
Hold onto those things
that you clock in yourself
because they will carry and buttress you
across much more than
purely the success lines
marching towards the end game
of a particular expertise.
The hobbyist matters enormously.
- [Brett] Okay, thank you.
We've come to the end everybody.
I love that at the very
end of every session
I turn to our guests and
say, any final comments,
final thoughts, and if I were
to ask, please, knowledge is?
(laughing)
- I kinda feel like it's really hard
to make a conclusion other
than where we had just landed
because there were so many profound ways
to think about knowledge
and to find the register
for yourself inside of that.
- I just want to say
thank you to all of you.
- Yes, thank you very much.
(audience applauds)
- Thank you, everybody,
Kristy Edmunds, Todd Presner,
Marcelo Suarez-Orozco, Victoria Marks.
Thank you so much for
sharing your knowledge
and helping us with all of ours.
Thank you.